elle s'appelle elodie jaffrelot à 33 ans
est maman d'une petite fille de 6 ans et
léna une situation somme toute classique
mais elodie est aussi atteinte de
troubles bipolaires un troubles survenus
après un choc j'ai perdu un enfant donc
à grosse dépression je pensais que
c'était juste une dépression sauf quand
on est enceinte de ma 2e de ma fille
j'ai des comportements un peu étrange
qui ont commencé à se révéler et on a
découvert que j'étais en phase maniaque
je ne dormais pas beaucoup j'avais très
peur de perdre un deuxième enfant
et du coup je me suis un petit peu fâché
avec beaucoup de monde dont une personne
très fortement
j'ai été au commissariat j'ai été amené
à l'hôpital et à l'hôpital le jour de
mon anniversaire le 3 mars 2015
un médecin m'a dit vous êtes bipolaire
le mot a été posée vous est porteuse de
troubles bipolaires
elodie était ensemble de sept mois
lorsqu'elle découvre que sa vie mais
aussi sa parentalité va changer après la
naissance de ma fille qui est née en
mars 2015 j'ai été pendant un mois dans
une unité au kremlin bicêtre qui
s'appelle d'unités par an béguin pour
voir si les liens avec ma fille était
correct donc les liens étaient bien
évidemment correct j'suis pas retourner
dans une vie normale moi et ma fille ma
mère m'a hébergé 3 1 avec un but she et
c'est ma maman qui s'occupait de la
petite le matin parce que je moi j'étais
fracassée par les médicaments
donc c'est elle qui s'occupait de la
petite du premier million de la changer
et cetera
depuis 2017 elodie a retrouvé son
indépendance et s'est installé dans un
appartement à guyancourt séparée du papa
elle garde sa fille à mi temps le
mercredis et les week-ends une situation
qui colle parfaitement avec sa
bipolarité à voir elena la moitié du
temps c'est beaucoup plus reposant si je
l'avais tout temps je serai être plus
irritables je serai débordé je serai
fatigué je recruterai gier à l'hôpital
pour moi la bipolarité c'était un
avantage et un inconvénient
l'inconvénient c'est que quand je suis
fatigué j'ai vraiment du mal à me lever
du mal à faire des choses et quand je
suis vraiment en phase d'exaltation on
peut faire énormément d'activités on
voit énormément de personnes ont fait
beaucoup de promenades
si sa bipolarité et donc stabilisé avec
un traitement au lithium et un suivi
chez un psychiatre
elodie à une crainte transmettre sa
pathologie à sa fille
ce qui me fait un peu peur c'est que ça
soit héréditaire et que ma fille du coup
soit malade plus tard alors j'y pense
pas je touche du bois je touche du singe
me touche aussi moi franchement par
rapport à la parentalité
c'est vrai que quand je suis fatiguée
c'est seulement ça qui est embêtant
après le reste du temps je suis bonne
maman et je pense que tout le monde
s'accordera à dire que je suis une bonne
amie elodie essaye de dépasser chaque
jour ses limites aussi bien dans sa
parentalité que dans sa bipolarité
en plus de ses activités bénévoles comme
le ramassage des déchets elodie
communique beaucoup sur son handicap sur
les réseaux sociaux
ça me fait du bien déjà d'en parler et
je me dis que si ça peut aider d'autres
familles d'autres personnes bipolaires à
à comprendre la maladie et ben ça serait
un plus en fait
moi je suis je pense que je suis né pour
vivre des choses compliquées les
surmonter et en parler et aider voilà
c'est ça ma devise en fait
et ledit compte bien mettre cette devise
à profit cette maman bipolaire est en
pleine reconversion
de quoi prouver que vie professionnelle
parentalité et bipolarité peuvent être
compatibles